[Music]
it might help to give a little
background why and how John Linden is
here tonight turns out that five the
long outboard members have worked with
John Rendon in the past at one meeting
or another Danny Hillis Peter Schwartz
Paul Sappho me and we just got reminded
Kevin Kelley John remembered Kevin in a
DARPA session that we were doing on the
future of science and Kevin and
forgotten the thing that all of us have
found is if there's some kind of
workshop or meeting and John Brendan is
there the workshop will go better he has
doesn't say much when he speaks up he
has extremely useful interesting stuff
to say and when you're working in
government meetings and workshops you
always wonder if it's going to connect
anything in the real world because
there's a lot of gears that don't
connect in government and when John is
there you know that the gears are
connecting because he is engaged and I
don't know what he's going to say
tonight which is part of the pleasure
for me because usually with our speakers
I sort of know in this case it's the man
and is the experience that we're
bringing and his interest in something
that long now is interested in well I've
talked to three people about how the
political process needs to engage a
important role of governance which is
long-term responsibility in a better way
that seems to have gotten out of whack
somehow and Madeleine Albright has said
she'd like to give them a talk on that
subject and Al Gore has said that he'd
like to give a talk on that subject in
this sequence when I raised the subject
with John Rendon last week at a workshop
we were at in Berkeley on the future of
Latin America he said he would like to
talk on the subject so please welcome
John Rendon
thanks Stuart good evening it's
important for full disclosure that I
share some observations first off these
will be my personal observations they
don't represent the government of the
United States other governments planets
solar systems also a thousand years ago
when I was 12 I served as executive
director and political director of the
Democratic Party I was director of
scheduling in advance for President
Carter and from time to time serve as an
analyst for BBC World Television it's a
small global audience of 365 million
people every day which in a global
information environment means that they
reach more people in one broadcast than
all the u.s. networks combined in fact
in the United States they have a larger
audience than a fox and MSNBC which is
two of our premier panic channels a
little humor is okay in this summer
I want to thank Stuart for inviting me
I've known Stuart for a few years he's a
brilliant insightful soul and probably
the first mythic poet I've ever met but
I was really sort of intrigued and not
baffled but moderately depressed by the
one of his emails either this afternoon
or yesterday when you said I'd come out
from behind the curtain and I don't know
25 26 years ago when I was the President
Carter's convention manager in New York
ABC did that piece about Oz and the
person behind the curtains I'm thinking
quarter century later I'm back doing the
same thing it's really a thousand years
ago I wanted to talk about a couple
things and Stuart touched on this I am
increasingly concerned about the
polarized nature of the nation and I
think it's harmful to the country
because people who hold views very
passionately and passion is a good thing
get attacked viciously by people on the
other side and as some people mentioned
me this morning there's no voice in the
moderate middle and what I wanted to do
is just to share some observations about
the war on terrorism and most
importantly against those observations
talk to you a little bit about the
length of and the nature of the conflict
and why I'm really happy and honored to
be here because I think you may be the
only group or continuing conversation
that's taking the long view to
everything or to anything plus you the
increasingly in Washington everybody is
consumed with today's news cycle the
tyranny of real time is Nik gowing who
is the principal presenter on BBC
describes it and nobody has taken any
time to think about time in a long view
and so I'd like to share those my
observations against that backdrop I
started with the notion that seventeen
hundred and fifty six days ago
there was an attack in and at the United
States and as I begin to think about
that it also occurred to me that 22,000
163 days ago in this very room the
United Nations started and if we look
back over that period of time and begin
to think about things in a longer
context we begin to sees things a little
bit differently at the start of the war
the information objectives of the US
military were really for to create and
maintain a coalition to counter deter
and defeat the enemy and the enemy would
change over time to support the
warfighter
if brave men and women are going to go
in harm's way they deserve support seven
days a week 365 days a year
not 9:00 to 5:00 Eastern Standard Time
to counter deter and degrade the
enlistment of potential terrorists so
let me talk a little bit about each one
of these in a little bit more detail I
think if you were being honest with
yourselves
and you asked yourself if this is really
a global war on terror
where America's war on terrorism you
would tell yourself that it's America's
war on terrorism and yet in open-source
reporting alone since September 12 2001
over 76 countries have conducted
unilateral operations against terrorist
targets or provided support to other
countries that were doing that and these
are countries that were saying so on
their own now admittedly in that some of
it is round up the usual suspects some
of his domestic political considerations
but there was enough that is going on in
different places and many countries are
participating so what does that mean
that means that probably the one of the
largest strategic conundrums of the war
is that the difference between
perception and reality is divergent the
perception is that it's America's war on
terrorism and there is enough comment
that it's really a global coalition
working in different places at different
times coalition's are as people in the
government would say a center of gravity
the relationship into the United States
and other countries is vital against
that backdrop the US government has a
huge credibility deficit when it
messages overseas and has so for a
number of years we must find ways not
just to engage the governments of other
countries but it's important and in our
vital interests that we engage the
people of other nations counter deter
and defeat the enemy and the enemy will
change over time we learned early on
because of the credibility deficit of
the government to talk about bin Laden
and Mullah Omar meant we actually
increase their value so the debate
shifted a little bit from people to
their organizations because we could
tell the truth and in that truth is what
al Qaeda sought to do was to turn
different countries into the next
Taliban state that dynamic has shifted
once again it's now important to talk
about the tactics they use and not
necessarily the people who use them
after all who could support someone that
puts a bomb on a school bus and kills
children who could support and this
actually is a real issue in Iraq now who
could support someone who stops a
busload of people and checks their IDs
and then selectively executes people
because of their name and then as we
begin to think about this we need to
think about the multiverse and not just
the universe what we do is we tend to
look at things just from our eyes and
not from others and this derives
together with the coalition strives to
gather the importance of other countries
and other cultures and they values that
they they bring to the fight now in
terms of what's going on now share these
observations first I think we're
fighting two wars where we should be one
is we're fighting a war that's comprised
of real terrorists coming at us and a
coalition partners whether it's London
Madrid Casablanca Amman names faces
places locations some of which we know
and some of which we don't that war is
being fought largely by the military and
the intelligence community and it's
being fought tens of thousands of miles
away from here
and sometimes close to the border or
even just inside the border with
law-enforcement agencies and that part
of the war quite candidly is going
fairly well a lots been stopped
sometimes in the middle of the night but
it's going fairly well the second war is
the war of potential terrorists some of
whom have alive and some of whom are not
yet born and that's the war I can
actually lose sleep over colleagues of
mine who are media analysts and native
language speakers from the region remind
me that in this war it's really not a
war of potential terrorists it's a war
of potential allies and these allies are
individuals and they're citizens
and here's the reason they say that if
you remember my comment earlier about
the credibility deficit when the US
government messages overseas and think
about this we say that it's not a war
against Islam and we run the risk that
1.2 billion people here that it is if 1
percent of them are violent extreme
actors bent on attacking and destroying
the United States of America and
coalition partners that's 12 million
people if they come with support
networks of 2 to 3 percent that's 48
million people now no government in the
United States regardless of political
party or ideology is going to authorize
the construction of a combat operations
plan that goes after 48 million people
one by one that means that if we don't
think long and think long sooner rather
than later we will be in a situation
where we will be fighting the fight and
not necessarily fighting to win so what
does that mean that means in reality the
threat comes not from the 12 million
people the 1% the threat comes from the
rest if we don't get them engaged in the
nature of this conflict what we need to
do is to it all borrow from Tom Friedman
on this we need to turn the street into
an active ally and away from being a
passive observer what we really need and
this is to think long again is we need
the parents in the countries to believe
because it is true that the American
people care more about their children
and their children's children than the
governments of the countries in which
they live if we don't start thinking
about the people in these countries
we're gonna miss an enormous opportunity
against that we have some choices and
challenges first we remain a peacetime
government while the military and others
are at war second we were an industrial
age structure and an Information Age
environment and that hasn't changed
third
we have tactical opportunities that
produce strategic threats this is the
temporal conundrum problem there right
now there are actions being conducted in
a number of places that meet a
requirement at a tactical or local level
now that could very well create a
strategic problem in the longer run and
then I think the single biggest threat
in the nature of the war is that the
United States unplugs from the rest of
the world and disconnects I know after a
recent debate in Congress which was very
vitriolic I had the opportunity to call
an old friend of mine it was a former
member of Congress and I told him that I
was afraid that the xenophobes were
over-represented in the Congress and
this guy with a good southern drawl Sen
Rendon you just might be wrong there are
a lot of them here so what does that
mean about the nature of the conflict
now early in the war I will go back now
to December 2001 and all of 2002 we
conducted a number of focus groups
globally we conducted them because we
weren't sure if the war was going to
break out where else it was going to go
so we used marketing techniques focus
groups as I just mentioned specifically
with the point of trying to find out
what people were saying because we
thought if the war was going to break
out it would have manifest itself in the
rhetoric of young people first so we did
gender divided age splits on youth 16 to
20 21 to 25 so here are the top lines of
that young Muslims said to us you look
at us but do not see us you talk to us
but do not listen you believe in
democracy inside your borders but not
outside and you lead in creation and
innovation but you do not share and I
look at that research probably once a
quarter and I ask myself how much has
changed and those views remain the same
across different countries and across
regions ironically to me the first
several of those points are virtually
identical to research that we saw in
late 60s and early 70s and in the early
70s I worked on phase two desegregation
in Boston and this look at us but do not
see us and talk to us but do not listen
was virtually identical to what we were
seeing across Boston and what we saw in
the civil rights movement across the
south the second set of research that we
took a look at really asked the question
about the United States do you support
the United States or not do you like the
United States or not the most
interesting question of that was what is
the United States to you and this is
where degrees of separation became very
important if the respondent to these
surveys had studied the United States or
worked in the United States or had an
immediate family member that did so
their definition the United States was
the American people and at that point it
was a high positive and a low negative
so you would think 80 something to teens
if they were two and three degrees of
separation out from that respondent they
defined US policy as American businesses
in the global marketplace McDonald's
Burger King Nike Reebok and that was in
the negative probably low 50s medium 40s
and if they were four and five degrees
of separation out from that their
definition of the United States was the
US government and that was a very high
negative to a very low positive in fact
it was inverted
if you thought about people who
respondents who defined the United
States as the American people versus
respondents who didn't know the American
people and defined it as US policy those
numbers were virtually identical but
inverted so a recent poll that pew did
pointed out some very interesting
numbers that in a number of countries
popularity or support of the United
States continues to decline
over time but there remains huge
separation in numbers between a
definition of the United States as the
American people and a definition of the
United States as US policy therein lies
a key in the long war in reality what
the United States really needs is the
strength and the credibility of the
American people to increase the strength
and the credibility of its government so
what about solutions talk a little bit
about networking strategy and I'm going
to do this from the same three places
that I just described in the early
polling numbers talk a little bit about
the government a little bit about the
private sector and then a little bit
about the American people first I think
the future is about convergence those of
you that are in technology would all see
that and a lot of the conversation is
about platforms on convergence but I
think it's about convergence not just in
communications but also in relationships
so what should the United States
government dude is shortened the long
war first we need to use soft power to
recover the credibility of the
government and it's not about spin it's
really about substance remember a friend
of mine describing a conversation with
President Clinton in Russia on a trip
that he went over there and the
president was troubled and for those of
you that know President Clinton you know
what troubled means and he was
expressing himself and those of you that
know President Clinton knows what that
means and he was outraged that the news
media would not give him credit for the
things that he was doing and one of
these senior aides turned to him and
said mr. president bad facts do not make
for good spin
we need to use soft power as Joe Nye
describes it to increase the credibility
of the government but what about issues
we share in common with different
populations I think one of the success
stories that hasn't been told as much as
it should have in the wake of the
wall coming down and the transformation
in the post-communist environment is how
much of a role the National Endowment
for democracy has played in giving
people an opportunity of empowerment and
an ability to express themselves and to
help with the formation the creation of
government's with that as a backdrop I
would encourage you to think about the
creation of a global Endowment for
education it's important that every
child on the planet has access to
education I would ask you also to think
about a global endowment for healthcare
this is really about prenatal health
care this is about immunization this is
about stopping diseases that break out
in these places and places that people
don't pronounce and haven't been to also
getting the visa issue right is vital in
our interest I have colleagues of mine
that have told me stories about what
it's like so I'm going to share one of
those with you now in some of our
embassies people spend the equivalent of
one month's salary for the privilege of
scheduling an appointment to stand in
line for four or five hours regardless
of the weather to go in and it's a
crapshoot and they bring their children
with them to find out whether or not
they can get a visa to come the United
States to visit and invariably depending
upon how they're treated or what the
process is like some of these parents
come out and they're actually crying
from the experience they've just gone
through and that's hard enough if you
think about somebody who wants to come
to the United States just as a visitor
this isn't a work permit and this
colleague of mine reminded me that it's
not just about the parents it's about
the children of the parents who've just
watched their parents be treated that
way and here not far away I mean in
Silicon Valley the whole emergence of
the Silicon Valley phenomenon had a lot
to do with people who came from other
countries who shared their insights
their observations learned and then
worked and helped make it productive
visas are vital connectivity is
essential whether it's the hundred
dollar laptops at the Media Lab we
have to find ways to get people
connected through technology through
experiences shared commonality all of
that becomes essential for those of you
that are active in alumni programs with
your respective universities or schools
alumni programs with international
students are essential the government
also has to do I think a better job with
engaging publics at home and at broad
dialog is helpful debate is essential in
fact it's vital to our national interest
after all how can we tell people that
it's important to come up and have a
democracy in a country if the debate
here isn't permitted at home and also I
think Universal Service which started
under the Clinton administration is also
important to keep in mind and this I
think a little bit about the Peace Corps
and I think about the experience in the
tsunami I think now is a year and a half
to almost two years ago I got one of the
first alerts in an activity that we
maintained about open source information
about the earthquake and then in
conversation shortly thereafter by email
with commander military commanders in
the Pacific and at other commands about
the fact that an eight point nine
earthquake was going to have havoc which
was what the first news report was and
that providing humanitarian assistance
was essential we watched with interest
over a period of time about how support
for the United States shifted in
Indonesia that over I guess the good
news as I told people later on is that
over thirty five days support levels for
the United States move 56 points that
was the good news the bad news was that
over 35 days support levels for the
United States move 56 points that if you
move that many points into that short a
period of time they can move back and if
there is not something that comes in
behind humanitarian assistance that has
enduring value on the ground can
actually lose the nature of the support
that was developed and now in Indonesia
the support levels of the United State
as of last month and pew was at 37% men
all set a peg off of what Joe Nye talks
in soft power is that there's also a
balance of smart power which is a new
characterization which is using both the
combination of strong or hard power and
soft power and applying it selectively
and then as I think about the government
and I watch everything that's transpired
over four years and I see frustration
not just in citizens but also in people
commanders and soldiers sailors airmen
and Marines I'm going and Crete I'm
becoming increasingly convinced that the
best role for the United States
government is to be the enabler and not
the actor the private sector this is
about connectivity again this is about
connectivity and technology connectivity
and education connectivity in health
care American businesses that operate in
the global market space that form part
of the definition of what the United
States is at an increasingly connected
world have increasingly responsibilities
increasing responsibilities not just to
their shareholders but also to the
citizens in the United States and
equally important if not more important
the citizens of the countries in which
they do business they've really got to
take a look at it and they've got to
engage at a much greater level about a
week ago I was in Germany for a meeting
and I was talking to somebody and she
had virtually perfect English and I said
to this person well where did you learn
your English and fully expected it to be
an English program in her school and she
said when she was growing up and going
to high school Volkswagen which was just
coming into the United States at the
time gives you an edge of the idea the
person because we could actually talk
about the beetle and she said Volkswagen
paid for her entire high school class to
study in the United States for one year
and paid for us students to go study in
Germany for one year
and I thought that was a tremendous
program and then I wonder about US
businesses that are operating out there
now whether they would consider doing
something similar or helping wire
schools and places in which they work
and then finally and most importantly
the American people what can they do
senator Kennedy has done a good job in
the United States Senate of establishing
the importance of building bridges but
bridges go both ways there are two way
streets and this ties back a little bit
to the United States government and what
it can do but if you think about the
world and think about the world in a
global context and the different
countries and cultures and I'm fortunate
to work in 91 of them the reality is
that we have much to learn from each
other this isn't about bringing people
over from other countries and asking
them to learn how we do things so that
they can do things better we have to
learn from them as well and so in that I
can also think about the importance of
education and this is sort of my magic
wand solution I ask colleagues from
time-to-time if they could do one thing
what is it that they would do that would
make a difference and my answer to that
question because I'm not immune is that
I would make the third year of high
school the United States mandatory
overseas and I don't care what direction
the students go if we lose touch with
the rest of the world then we'll see the
rest of the world as a threat and not as
an opportunity and the diversity of this
nation is what produces the strength and
the character the American people along
with that we can do a lot with health
care this is about building partnerships
I like the concept of the bridges that
that Senator Kennedy talked about but
health care and communities across
America should be related to health care
and communities across the middle east
related to communities across asia we
should be able to use the technology
that has made such a big difference in
everybody's lives certainly in this room
across the country an ability to build a
bridge on education our ability to build
a bridge on health care and then also on
communications and I would say this to
the news
across the United States you're not
absent from this either I think that
newspapers in the United States could do
a lot worse than trading one position
and partnering out with a news
organization in the Middle East I would
think for example in my own state of
Massachusetts the Boston Globe could
send one journalist to work for Al Hayat
and take one journalist from Al Hayat to
the Boston Globe for a year I think that
helps this is about understanding each
other it's not about being right and
then finally I think we have to think
about how jobs how economics works in a
number of these countries and a number
of these cultures and give people access
to that very innovation and that they
see in the United States that they
admire and that they respect and that
they think we keep away from them so
finally before I get to the 4312
questions that you've obviously
collected let me just address the future
a little bit I think the future rather
than my comment about the final frontier
in San Francisco and the Starship
Enterprise I would tell you that I think
that the the final frontier is really
about networks and narratives
desperately in search of an alliteration
he said the networks are all about
linked people organizations the
scalability social networks not just
hard wired networks I think we really do
have to find a way to have people
communicate communicate across
boundaries and boundaries and borders I
think the old exact the old definition
of borders no longer works and I think
also that this multiverse each of you
has a universe around yourselves or if
you're here with family members it's
around your family members and you come
together and it pulls apart at different
times we have to understand that
everybody sees something live something
differently and that those that
multiverse is essential and then it's
about the narrative I think a lot about
this too in the context of the long war
what is it that people will be taught in
schools five years from now around the
world about what transpired over the
last five years whoever writes that
narrative will probably decide we'll
play a big role on whether the war is a
hundred months long at that point or a
hundred years long this narrative will
become essential and how will those
stories be handed down family to family
neighborhood to neighborhood generation
to generation this narrative is
essential and how that story be told in
movies which after all are our tools of
time it's about networks and it's about
the narrative and then I come back to my
concern about the crossroads the
countries in and so I took a little bit
from Robert Frost's two paths and I
wonder if we could think about this from
the nation's perspective and I too will
be telling this with a sigh that
somewhere ages and ages hence two roads
diverged in a wood and I I took the one
less traveled by and as the political
discourse in the nation polarizes even
more that road that's less traveled by
which is maybe the one of civilized
discourse that's the one that will make
all the difference and it will make the
difference over months over years and
over the ages Robert Frost described so
thank you very much for having me I
promise Stewart that I'd actually leave
time for questions and also for answers
so thank you very much and Stewart I
don't you come up here now I guess
[Applause]
you're fast John thank you that was one
of the briefest most extinct talks we've
had here which is great because it gives
us lots of time to to wade into
questions and Kevin is going to bring up
some while I fake around up here one
thing we are talking about backstage was
you mentioned that you don't read
American media or a few of varrock
American media very much anymore you
want to say what that's about I to the
extent that I have read it and see
television which is a short period of
time I get concerned that the media in
the United States is absent context and
perspective that it's a rush to news
it's more important to be first than to
be right and I think that's a very
serious problem I disclosed earlier that
I do on-camera work from time to time
it's been a little bit since I've been
on on BBC but what's always struck me
interesting on BBC is that for BBC their
news they ordered the news in order of
importance and everybody will say well
that's what they do in the United States
as well but they'll open up the first
story for the length to be able to get
into virgin views and for them they
don't consider their newscaster or the
correspondents talent they consider them
journalists and so there are times when
you have really significant stories
whether it was Sarajevo or Christina
we're out of their 30 minute newscast
they would give up 20 21 22 23 minutes
to the story to be able to talk about
different things and on most US networks
you can't get beyond two minutes and
some of these stories are so complex and
have so much behind them that it's
important to get more than two minutes
of news and so we don't do that and you
watch foreign media it sounds like
professionally is that something that
people who on the Internet can do close
to as well as the render
does well I mean the business answer to
that is no but the reality is probably
yes I think well I plug BBC so enough
with that it would depend on the area of
the church they're really different
segments of time that become important
there is a real-time environment which
is the quick term this is what's going
on right now and in the course of real
time in that space we've been pioneers
since the mid 80s in the course of a
year we'll be able to see things and
actually beat CNN as a standard twenty
five hundred times a year in terms of
stories that we see globally that have
the potential to break out of the box
that's a different kind of environment
that's much harder to do the near
real-time environment which is an
ability to get information that is
nested which for those if there's
anybody in the room from the news media
or owns or operates the news media is
where I think it's going to go is nested
information then that's what individual
citizens can do and I would encourage
them to do that the risk and the
polarized nature of the nation goes to
the discourse which is almost like the
Google zone video was on the net I don't
know six seven years ago I forget
because people are only that my fear is
that people will only go online to get
news that reaffirms their belief sets
and what you really need to do is go
what one really needs to do is go online
and see what's really out there even if
they're diametrically opposed in order
to find where the truth lies in this
because it's really easy to feel good
about yourself in your arguments but
it's harder to open up the aperture so
you can see somebody else's point of
view this would strike me as a dot org
opportunity maybe it already exists and
I haven't seen it well it was something
that would basically collect such a
combination of sort of welcome and
unwelcome stuff that you'd read it for
the welcome stuff and then stay for the
unwelcome stuff and broaden a couple of
questions that kind of go to
where that your talk started one from
looks like Ricardo McGann leave a hand
if you want to indicate where you are
how do you tacitly explain still using
the term war on terror without quotes do
you believe the term still has relevance
when even the White House is trying to
retire the term out of embarrassment can
you just repeat that war on terror you
you use it seriously as in the title is
that still the best terminology no it's
great what should we use I don't I don't
know I I had this conversation with the
Brits about two weeks ago
III think all four words should be in
play including pronouns I I think I'm
open to suggestions on what to call it
it's hard I think global makes sense
because it's going on around the world a
war probably while there is combat
operations occurring on a daily basis
I'm not sure war is the right way
because it doesn't give a sense of
longevity thought about the word
campaign because it's a long effort I
think everybody's against terrorism but
everybody defines terrorism differently
and the perpetrators or terrorism are
defined differently depending upon the
people with whom you speak and that's
where it gets to be complicated so I'm
open to suggestions I mean if anybody
wants to send in suggestions but it's
also important to know that it's not my
decision okay
one of the things I've been going around
saying just see what happens is the war
on terror is over
we lost we've already spent a trillion
dollars basically frightening ourselves
to death I didn't have to do they lost
by color because quite a lot of film I
know sexually yeah quite a lot of
al-qaeda has been taken down and the
term war lost because it helped lead us
into probably a primrose path to put it
over mildly in Iraq war is a term which
itself was problematic even though you
know you have military people engaged
yeah I just ran that out for a second go
ahead with when I met with people
defense attache is actually from Europe
this was last fall the they made
virtually the same points that you just
did but for them the problem with the
word wars it conjures up the political
memories of World War one in World War
two and it's a politically an enactment
to them and so they were searching for
alternative ways to describe them it's a
problem a number of people recognize it
but like health care in the United
States and ever people recognize that's
a problem and nobody can sort of agree
on the solution another issue I find
with the problem is when you're in a war
absolutely everybody is engaged in it
every day and the problem with this
so-called war is practically nobody is
engaged in it every day and so it
doesn't feel right there's everything is
kind of skewed partly because of that as
we were saying backstage the troops and
their families know it's a war but it's
weird for them when they come back and
they find a country that is not in the
same war they are so back to this Dean
Coley whatever hand if you want says
whatever we call it how do you know when
you've won yeah that's a real problem
when is this thing over well that's why
I think it's a long war it's easy in
conventional operations to decide who
wins and who loses this is an asymmetric
activity and it's hard to have that
definition I think the original
construct in 2001 was publicly known as
2 plus 7 which was bin Laden and Mullah
Omar in the circle 7 on the out the next
circle out all of whom have been killed
or captured but just like you said I
mean they've changed too they've adapted
they've morphed there are proxies and
therein lies the problem there there are
people still attacking and it's hard to
define
in the terms of that victory how you can
tell you're going to win which is what
makes the use of the word war
problematic you know in that construct
exactly here's a question from Danny
Hillis in the front this is going to
something you race at the very beginning
what do you think is the root cause of
the polarization of politics that you
described in your introduction actually
you and I talked about that also before
yeah I wanted to blame Newt Gingrich and
you said no yeah no I don't I don't
blame the former Speaker I I'm sort of
struck I remembered it a little bit
differently
I actually remember a speech President
Carter gave in the 1980 general election
where he expressed his concern that the
debate in the United States was dividing
black from white rich from poor
Christian from Jew and that that would
happen if Ronald Reagan got elected so I
don't know when it started I know that
as a political tactic wearing a hat from
probably fifteen hundred years ago when
I worked elections in the United States
it became evident that in the mid 70s
that there was a tactic or a strategy
that was using tactics to depress
turnout as a function of negative
campaigning and the emergence of
negative campaigning did had some
unintended consequences were intended
consequences I don't know but I think
they've remained true today that the
consequences of negative campaigning is
that the polarized elements of society
feel stronger about who they are and the
people in the middle don't believe that
the government represents them or the
campaigns represent them and so they
choose not to participate and they tune
out and that reduces participation that
participation allows the polarized
elements to succeed and I think that's a
threat to the country
a question here on this is from Steve
Wall Rob to what extent have you
questioned your own assumptions about
who and what was behind 9/11 and the war
on terror well that's a really good
question
it should also say how often I'll make
it to general more general what
interesting things you've found you've
been wrong about in recent years I can
do that well there are a couple things
that I do regularly one I go back and I
look at the recruit and maintain a
coalition counter to turn defeat an
enemy support the warfighter degrade the
recruitment or enlistment of potential
terrorists and I on a regular basis look
and try to assess how well the coalition
is doing in that space
well the assumptions of 9/11 I don't do
that as often as that but I do it
regularly and I try to turn it around
from another perspective I look at how
the United States is operating not as a
government but as a nation and I wonder
what happens in different places around
the world because of the shift of
resources to conduct combat operations
which is hugely expensive the United
States stopped doing a number of things
in a number of countries and so vacuum
has were created two other people have
stepped into those vacuums so that if
you're going to take a look and ask
who's behind any kind of activity or
what's going on you'd always have to ask
yourself who benefits from that and I
think that it's important to look at the
assumptions on 9/11 to see if there is
somebody else playing on the stage that
we can't see that is here but but I
don't have any conclusions on that I
just continue to ask the question same
question different answers any other
interesting changes of mind on that on
any of the stuff you've been dealing
with the last few years
I mean we both encountered elected
officials who basically are thinking
whatever they thought back in Seattle
before they got elect and you know
sometimes their staffs keep up but
changes of mind when in a power position
are relatively rare as everybody's day
is full and they're playing out whatever
theory of the world they have so they
count on people like you and others that
are hired like me I suppose to think
through what are some changes of either
frame or actual 180 perspective change
that is worth having and we do that best
when we notice it in ourselves serious
stuff I've been wrong about I could go
on for an hour you know how do we get
that frame of mind into the power
positions I I think this tyranny of real
time that Nik gowing wrote about 10
years ago it's a good paper if you
haven't seen it I encourage you to take
a look at he wrote it around the
experience in Bosnia this tyranny of
real-time information and the decision
cycle has I mean the the velocity and
acceleration has increased beyond
comprehension and so I think that the
best counsel I would give anyone to
continue to give them is we have to find
a way to slow time down in order to
bring in enough information so that the
decisions that are made in the
strategies that are velop are informed
and are can be accomplished in a timely
fashion
this notion that we have to do something
immediately is when we find ourselves to
be most vulnerable particularly the US
government I think because it remains as
I said in my talk an industrial age
structure and an Information Age
environment so the quicker the the
timing cycle the more the government can
find a way not to act which is different
than slowing time down you have to slow
down to be able to see enough things
okay couple questions on credibility
Jeff yanker puts it cleanest says why do
you think we have a credibility gap then
Carol Brule
who's a congressional candidate says the
US government has lost credibility in
the world most people believe Bush
Cheney to be criminals could the u.s.
redeem itself in the eyes of the world
by impeaching Bush Cheney and changing
us is destructive global domination
policy and Jo rut it looks like says
wouldn't the best and most ethical way
for the u.s. to overcome a credibility
deficit to become more credible in the
context of that question here is the
Stan can you speak to your own company's
perceived role spreading disinformation
yes yes no yes yes no yes next question
the the the challenge in credibility the
reason I told that the Clinton story
from Russia is that you you can't spin
your way out of a bad fax situation if
credibility is important that then
incredibly is important because you're
going to do what you're going to say
what you say and thank you
people understand that but the actions
of a government whether it's the United
States government or other governments
has to be rooted in a moral authority
and that raises all sorts of different
implications the credibility issue that
the United States government has had and
this is where context and perspective
are important and where the discourse
really should take into account a little
bit of history while the credibility of
the US government continues to decline
it's important to realize that it's been
declining for a while not just through
one administration and that goes to the
fact that the United States takes out
positions that are probably inconsistent
with the populations or the street in a
number of the countries therein lies
that problem with respect to the last
question of the sequence mm-hmm can I
speak to the credibility of my
organization yes I mean those that know
us know that we strongly believe and
have always believed in timely truthful
and accurate information never said
anything different have always made that
argument to policy makers who establish
policy we don't we've made the argument
to the public affairs community when
they communicate and we made the
argument to the psychological operations
community when they communicate we make
that argument to the information
operations community when they
communicate but you know there will
always be stories that will be out there
about people and some will be true in
some loan
and that's just the nature of the
digital age well there's a question
related to that of Courtney pepper for
O'Dwyer's Dwyers is this a an ad no no
actually it's a public relations
publication right brilliant thank you
okay
you have been relatively quiet since the
Rolling Stone article this was James
Bamford article called the man who sold
the war and tend to be behind the scenes
why speak now invited this audience and
there's the thanks which I think just
thanks for being here
I've been relatively quiet no I well as
I mentioned at the start of the talk
it's not been relatively quiet Sims
since James Bamford is peace I think
he's a brilliant author by the way I
should just tell you that but he doesn't
always get everything right either but I
came here to have this conversation
first because it's what I said at the
start of the talk the only organization
only group continuing conversation
that's taking the long view at
everything or at anything as I said in
the beginning and I think that's
important if we're gonna truly
understand the nature of the conflict in
which the country finds itself then we
have to start taking longer and longer
views of time and of history of
opportunities and of threats and if my
presence can produce a little bit of
debate dialogue or discourse on that
subject then it's a helpful and useful
amount of time I've got a couple
specific follow-up questions too from
David Martinez one I'm going to pass on
from fellow wrote me mr. Chatterjee
Martinez question what was your role in
setting up the Iraqi National Congress
what do you now think of Amin Chalabi
and Judith Miller to what was Paul
Moran's role in helping the US military
and/or the CIA mr. Chatterjee's question
is were you involved in Jessica link or
Lynch or set him a statue toppling
events I'm going to separate the two
because it's important to do that on the
Jessica Lynch thing absolutely nothing
to do with it
do you think the word first went out
from military people that she you know
was heroic and everything they just do
that routinely or what I'm sorry
never the word went out at first that
she was floating fighting heroically
before she was captured and all that
stuff same thing with Petzl and where do
these things come from in the military I
have no idea where that came from I mean
we I remember the day of the convoy
being attacked and there was a lot of
confusion and and the military says is
that all reports change as a result of
contact with the enemy as you know and
we were monitoring open source
information related to that attack which
included Al Jazeera television trying to
get some sense of what was going on and
fighting heroically I have no idea what
I've never walked that back I mean
because at that period of time our
participation with respect to Iraq was
monitoring international news media I
mean that's what that was but let me go
to the and I'm not sure you're gonna
like the answer but let me go to the I
NC and the questions associated with
that which are also one of the tenants
of the Bamford piece there is work that
we do that is classified and I'm not
going to talk about that work here or in
other places because I don't think
ethics are a thing of convenience
I think ethics matter I think have you
taken oath it's got a matter
and with respect to anything associated
with that I can't talk about it even if
the news media happens to get it right
or get it wrong Oh
what's your migrating opinion of chala P
I mean I guess known him for a while and
he's gone through a lot of this
Institute's
yeah and my answer is going to be the
same with respect to that not today no
I'm just not I'm not gonna answer that
one this is you know okay to do he's
answering a lot here more generically
this is question from Kevin Kelly
removed her right to the top of the
stack is a democratic government ever
justified either by war or emergency to
deceive the public are there some kinds
of wars for misleading the public is
needed how does the government prevent
itself from deceiving itself that's a
really good question I think the more we
get into a connected world the more we
get into a global information
environment the harder of the and harder
it gets for any kind of deception to get
traction that what you have is a lot of
people operating you know we almost have
a ubiquitous transparent environment and
so it would be hard to get away with
something like that
should a government be able to deceive
its population it depends on the stake
actually not many people are going to
like the answer but you had the question
that they always come back to I think
Anthony Cave Browns description in World
War two of having broken the codes that
the Nazis were using they allowed the
Germans to bomb I think it was Coventry
if I remember correctly and not stop it
for fear of losing the capability
the Brits will even tell you today that
their most successful deception
operation in the world war two dealt
with shifting Nazi military assets off
of Cyprus and away from a pretendin
attack potential or pending attack in in
Europe I think that was the the body of
the man that never existed
whatever that was the problem without
having a this is why you really do one
really does need competing intelligence
sources and that's to create enough flow
of information where one can get a
better sense of everything that's going
on the risk is what you know the risk is
if the government becomes
self-reinforcing where it only wants to
see its view and doesn't want to allow
disparate views and it's important to
have the disc use in even if you don't
agree with them you break that cycle
when it's happening because you must
have seen it happen I've seen it happen
well you know you raise your hand and
you say yeah I think you're wrong you
know at some point somebody's animating
so how does that work I don't know you
know there's a lot of frustration in the
government not just with the government
about this people who've worked in the
government for years can be frustrated
about the absence of an ability to have
that kind of exchange but but I don't
have a solution to that other than to
say you have to allow the district
reviews in and it could very well be
that the solution said for that comes
not inside the US government but to the
US government from coalition partners
and that in fact coalition's which tend
to see things differently than in the
United States should be allowed to have
a fraternal seat at the table and not a
paternal existence with us we go back
around the importance of coalition's
that's nice right let me go a little
deeper in that one because I was sort of
introduced as subject by a mild mentor
and Gregory Bateson was anthropologist
who had a role in world war two with his
wife Margaret Mead as he
first thing you do in a war is line up
all the Liberals and point them at the
enemy and he and his wife Margaret were
pointed by Roosevelt's White House at
both Germany and Japan and first they
were involved in helping Americans
understand Brits so we would be good
allies and then Gregory was in the South
Pacific with the OSS pre CIA thing doing
black radio and black radio I don't know
if he devised it but he was helping make
it happen was radio broadcast in
Japanese as if by the Japanese colonial
powers that exaggerated in a really
unpleasant way everything of the
Japanese were actually saying so they
just basically said the stuff and then
cubed it and put it in such a way the
Japanese could never deny it because it
was in line with what they were saying
but it was so repulsive that of course
people who heard it would not want
anything to do with this new empire say
again like Fox News says Danny Hillis
less profitable perhaps no advertising
revenue worth engineer but this kind of
disinformation is standard I mean Sun
Tzu is full of it and so on that you you
you are always trying to keep the enemy
off-balance and yourself from going
off-balance but in the long war that you
just described for credibility is of the
essence and you can was sort out who's
going to be a terrorist from who's going
to be an ally and so you can't target
the way you could and say World War 2
quote the enemy against those that they
were trying to take over does that kind
of is this fundamentally a different
game and the role of deception in this
quasi military intelligence rich domain
is it different now and are we catching
up with how different it is yet the you
know I think about the radio but then
also thinking about ubiquitous
transparency I think if anybody stood up
a black radio opera and that's the
characterization for those that don't
know it's black gray and white but but
if anybody stood that kind of activity
up now I think enough people would point
out that it didn't make any sense where
it came from and it would probably take
about 72 hours before it would no longer
have any credibility so I don't think
that that can happen anymore I think
they're probably fundamentally different
tools that that are needed in the nature
that we were talking a little bit about
Lebanon backstage which is the breaking
news right now what's your perception on
the gravity of that well sort of been
out of touch most of the day my guess is
it'll be interesting to see if this is a
news report so they're probably about 15
or 20,000 American citizens in Lebanon
and my instinct is that that there's
probably a plan or somebody should be
planning now for evacuation or at least
protection of American citizens is that
right
when did it get there in March No
okay all right so I yeah okay the USS
Iowa is there and they're conducting
evacuation operations now of US citizen
American citizens okay
I don't have enough flow of information
to give you a sense of what I think is
going on there but I can tell you that
what usually happens in a continent and
emergent emergent and immediate conflict
situation is that the countries that
tend to have the most citizens present
have plans that they pull off the
bookshelf
well one second for the different people
that are there and then they try to get
their own nationals out because the
responsibility of its government is
first to its own people so for example
in I think in Ivory Coast a year or so
ago when there were really serious
problems the french led the emergency
evacuation operations and allowed other
countries to come in but in terms of
what's going on on the ground there I
just I don't have any visibility on it
right coming back to a general point
from Rocky how do we educate others when
their governments when their governments
stability depends on portraying us as
the enemy
well I that would go to my point I think
about the importance of increased
connectivity and developing
relationships National endowments of
Education and of health care and the
role I think that the American people
need to play in this ricardo american
you've got another card you mentioned
that you think competing intelligence
agencies are positive does this mean you
think that the consolidation of agencies
under one ages as the white house is
trying to do is a bad move too early to
tell whether it's a bad move or not
whether and i think it'll be a while
before people know and what would be the
science it's a bad move well I mean
obviously mistakes more mistakes
Plan B well this is interesting Stewart
candy was a intern working at the London
Eye Foundation says how far into the
future do you have to look before the
concept of American national interest
indeed any national interest evaporates
into absurdity can we govern for that
timeframe
in other words sir you know one of the
things that I think we were saying is
that politics absolutely engrosses us in
the moment now there's a lot of division
political division us but as as you
expand your time frame politics sort of
becomes noise and the other structure
emerges and so this question is in the
sense what's the how does one engage the
time frame at which engrossing national
interest drops into something stronger
and bigger I mean this this goes again
to the the threat of the dynamic with
the the tyranny of real time if all we
handle is the next news cycle then we
really create a dynamic in which
everybody's looking at their feet
nobody's looking at the horizon and if
you have to look at the horizon in order
to put some things into play that could
be harvested or beneficial later on and
then that increases the amount of
opportunities policy makers have
operators have down the road if all we
do is just feed the daily news cycle and
that crunch then it's limited
opportunities you have a chance to
succeed if you think long rather than
just playing short what that time
horizon is how far out can you look and
be realistic I don't know my guess is I
would start with a 20-year timeline and
then work back from that but I would
probably adjust it every year and then
if you think about it from a government
standpoint the US government budget
cycle is one year so if you're really
gonna think in the cutting cycles too
long effort then you have to fund things
that will go on for a long time but I
mean okay the budget cycle is one year
the voting cycle is two years in
Congress
the polling cycle is one day it is
longest what and those are all very
powerful that is people respond to them
with real behavior what might engage
somehow balance that I mean adaptivity
calls for that kind of fast response
that's great but how do you balance it
with something else yeah you want a
government to be accountable to its
people so you don't want to change the
timing cycle of Elections but you have
to find a way to set in motion a series
of practices or procedures that would
enabled people to take some issues a
little bit longer than two years or one
year on a budget cycle in theory that
really was bipartisan approaches to
fundamentally large issues you know
whether it was the space program or the
Cold War and the days of when the
dynamic tension of polar opposites in
the Congress yielded in legislation that
was in the best interest of the nation
the Kennedy Goldwater dynamic rather
than the dynamic tension of polar
opposites creating more and more tension
and less and less discourse so part of
the Cure might be getting some kind of
bipartisan projects that have this long
term time frame the people are
comfortable with and then that becomes a
standard enough so that other things
tend to be spoke enough in its time
frame yeah I think that's probably right
you know and then borrowing a line from
the Congress heaven forbid reserving the
right to revise and extend my remarks I
would tell you that it probably would
make sense given your construct to start
with people who were retired rather than
those that were active and let it work
itself institutionally back from those
that had been there here's a question
from Roger David which goes to a
question of agenda it seems that many of
us - many of us that the war on terror
is not the real agenda it might be power
might be wealth it might be oil some
kind of geopolitical control
my sense is that there's a double
confusion here one is is there an agenda
and two is it 1 which we can know and
participate in in Israel one which is
disreputable and therefore it isn't
shared because they won't be supported
in other what's the agenda of current
activities related to Iraq and the
so-called war on terror yeah I'm not
sure where to go with that question the
reality is the soldiers are fighting and
dying over there as they are in
Afghanistan and other places as for any
agenda I mean from the think the
commander is over the troops standpoint
you know there is our to achieve their
mission all right
they don't see agendas you know they see
their missions day in and day out
I know but I said beginning these are my
personal observations I'm not here
representing the government the two
words that are actually correct in this
case our national security US was
attacked it didn't happen
you heard it here John
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you for making the point that this
is indeed the disputatious time and set
of issues and and that's indeed why
we're here we got some specifics here
one from Brent Ross what in your view is
the source of the emboldened attitudes
of leaders in North Korea and Iran was
it rain headed for a more moderate
regime before we invaded Iraq do you
think I think personal observation of
North Korea's that it's just an entirely
different environment they see things
differently than then I've never been
there have not met with them do you have
any sense of public opinion in North
Korea at all no none at all I've talked
to people who have gone there for
meetings to try to get some sense and
their view of what's going on in the
rest of the world is just dramatically
different than everybody else's view
it's perfectly acceptable and a normal
course of a year that two or three
members of somebody's extended family
will die from starvation that's just
normal so they don't see that as an
abnormal activity we find it to be wrong
with respect to Iran it's it's a really
interesting construct of whether a more
moderate regime would have been elected
had we not been in Iraq I don't have any
data to that to know whether that be
true or not there is in increasing at
least in the open source environment
almost as if North Korea and Iran are
playing off of each other but not with
each other so they watch how one country
emerges and does something and then they
learn from that and the other country
does something they go back and forth
but they've spread that out over a long
enough period of time and actually some
French journalist pointed out how they
saw that going back and forth when
that's going on how do we interrupt that
cycle well there are other people that
are playing into that as well I mean the
Europeans have a very big stake in that
and so it's not just us versus those two
countries there are a lot of other
countries that feel strongly about it
and they're engaged in that as well um a
couple questions here out in Afghanistan
maybe the easiest thing would just be to
ask what's your perception of
state of things in the likely sequence
of events in Afghanistan Afghanistan
continues to progress more and more
children are going to school get a sense
of that when one is there the violence
in Afghanistan tends to be located in
the drug producing provinces the open
source polling in Afghanistan remains
positive no interest in the Taliban
coming back Taliban support levels are
in single digits from Afghans with the
exception of the three southern
provinces where they're in the teens so
it's not overwhelming numbers they're
joined in that up or down it sort of
stayed constant over the last two or
three years even though the violence in
the country has increased mm-hmm the
specific question that from Brian Goode
has given the likelihood the profits
from the resurgent Afghan opium trade
are going to al-qaeda why is this issue
so obscure in public policy discussion
why is it what so obscure in public
policy discussion the whole opium trade
question uh I don't know I mean I think
it's significant a number of countries
have continued to raise that in their
own media that the importance of paying
attention to it so I don't know why it's
not there
okay a couple more JD Ross Leigh he says
what he mean by open source
okay open-source media distinguish from
open source code well open source media
is anything that is published printed
appears on television or radio generated
by a news organization and that's open
source media from Sam why is it that
military or recruitment in the US has
declined whereas recruitment of
insurgents in Iraq has increased I'm not
sure either one of those assumptions is
accurate I remember of course you'd
expect me to say that but I remember
seeing numbers in a story this week
where recruitment levels in the US Army
in particular had exceeded expectations
and that the other services had met
their goals oh is that one
okay I don't work retention or
recruitment now something that is part
of the one of many divisions going on in
the US I used to be in the Army I was
the infantry lieutenant and taught basic
training just before Vietnam brought
some of the troops I trained probably
went there I was near born and jumped
out of airplanes and I was in the army
because I was in ROTC at Stanford
Stanford doesn't have our OTC anymore
neither do any of the IVs and one of the
byproducts of the Vietnam War was
basically of various student activities
chased ROTC off the northern campuses
where they went is to Southern Christian
colleges I heard this from West Clark a
couple months back back when he's
running for president
and so you for the first time you have a
junior officer corps which is not urban
not highly educated pretty seriously
Christian and of a different political
stamp than we used to have the other
thing going on and it's always been the
case is the military is largely made up
from people from rural areas not from
the cities we had our first San
Franciscan died in Iraq this month and
so there's a division that occurs
between rural Sensibility and urban
Sensibility the rural people are feeling
this war personally much more than the
city people are and how that will play
out politically I have no idea because
those are you know in many cases red
states but it is I felt when I was in
the military that the division between
the civilian life and military life was
way too great and that you know part of
the broad education everybody being
aware of each other's realities that you
talk about this is another thing which
we as civilians
can help engage for example a good
interesting movie that's just out there
now is called the war tapes where you
see a bunch of National Guard guys from
I think New York State going on the
first tour to Iraq and bear in mind a
lot of soldiers are up to their fourth
tour now and the thing that struck me is
a former Regular Army guy was how
untrained these weekend warriors wore to
be sent into a ferociously real military
environment and they did pretty well
considering and they got seriously
[ __ ] up as happens under this
especially this kind of war where you
never know who the enemy is and when the
reserves and National Guard come back to
the u.s. unlike a regular army
all of whom get counseling now so nobody
feels bad about getting counseling
none of the reservists and National
Guard get counseling they are back in
their families suddenly they look around
and the town they're in doesn't know
about the war welcomes them home big
parade but that's pretty much the end of
it there's some good bonding going on
between the Vietnam vets who went
through another version of this and the
Iraq war vets but it's also something
that I think we could engage sorry even
the wolf's feature but I'm curious what
you think of that John talk about one
sure yeah Admiral Stockdale just died he
was the guy who was tortured and kept
from telling that nothing actually
happened in the Gulf of Tonkin ok you're
looking at me with wonder
yeah I am I'm you deal with military a
lot what's your perception on this
civilian military saying I I think I
think there are several aspects to it
that are important and part of it goes
to troop rotations and part of it goes
to preparation and then part of it goes
to the practices or procedures when
forces cycle home the larger issue with
respect to how the US government
functions is that as I mentioned on the
talk the Industrial Age structure but
here's the dynamic if you've got forces
that are deployed or people that work in
embassies or people that do different
jobs and they cycle out whether they are
active to the reserve or guard or in the
civilian side of the government the old
industrial age structure said ok you
move on to your next post and so what
happens is you tend to lose the
experience and expertise of the people
that were there people come back in and
they start at zero so I think about that
in the context of forces that get
deployed to combat environments like
Iraq or Afghanistan and someplace in
Baghdad probably right now sometime in
the morning I guess timewise there's a
patrol on a street and somebody will
start yelling at the Patrol or something
and then the question is what is the
young lieutenant leading that patrol
going to do and chances are that that
she can talk to her captain and figure
out what to do in that situation but
probably they all went there at the same
time and if there was a way that she
could have ahead of time talk to the
person who led that patrol for the
previous half year or whole year to
realize that the person yelling you know
yells every day
about anything or everything and that
you can quiet them down by talking to
their sister you know or their cousin or
their uncle that lives on that street
it's losing that sense because you know
some of the forces that rotate or
underlap they're not overlapped even if
you're overlapped it's probably not a
long period of time but then the same
thing is true in the embassies it's as
if we haven't made any functional
changes to accommodate the nature of
this the government continues to do
business as usual now much too I think
secretary Rice's credit she's begun to
take a hard look at embassies in Europe
and staffing patterns and wondering why
some of the European embassies are so
large and shouldn't that for those
personnel there get relocated develop
expertise in Arab countries Arab lines
of skills and recycled because the
construct of the embassies is a
post-world War two cold war environment
and she's the first one to have looked
at the size of the embassies against the
nature you know of the conflict terms of
forces coming home it's something that
we shouldn't lose sight of and they need
to be treated correctly and they
shouldn't be left alone
there shouldn't be a difference between
active duty and Guard and Reserve and
the fact that some of the people that
were active in the Vietnam veterans
movement have tied up with them is
probably a really excellent thing
general question and we can finish with
from Phil Bush in the long long sense
does your belief of the nature of man
include the possibility of world peace
yeah I actually do I'm an optimist in
that sense despite the fact that nobody
here tonight will believe that I do
think that there is a possibility to
probably see an end to the conflict as
we know it today
although the earlier question about how
do you define victory looms large in
that construct if we don't start
thinking long maybe this is a good way
to and if we don't start thinking long
and we keep fighting in these shorter
and shorter timing cycles the war
doesn't end if we do think long and put
some of these things into practice and
I'm sure that people in the audience
here in this room and then probably
online have a number of ideas what can
be done in the role American people can
play in it if we start putting some of
those ideas into motion and we really do
start playing long at the same time
we're playing short thinking long and
acting long it's probably possible to
have the length of the conflict every
year we play long and that would
probably mean since I've been telling
people that I see it over a hundred
years now that probably the end of seven
or eight years you'd a dramatically
different conflict but that requires
people in this room your audience around
the country to participate in it and not
just observe it so thank you for having
me thank you for coming okay
[Applause]
[Music]